bonsoir soir comment vivez vous cet
événement d'abord est-ce que vous vous
attendiez à ce que vladimir poutine
procède de la sorte parce qu'au
lendemain finalement de cette
conversation avec emmanuel macron qui
avait fait dire au président français
que nous nous acheminions vers un sommet
pour trouver une issue diplomatique à
cette crise il acte de l'indépendance de
ces deux régions ukrainienne oui enfin
ce qu'il a décidé aujourd'hui ce soir
président poutine n'a rigoureusement
rien à voir avec les trois points qui
ont été évoqués dans le que dans le
compte-rendu de conversations entre
monsieur poutine et monsieur mâcon hier
donc on n'est pas tout à fait sur la
même planète là est la première chose
d'eux et vous pensez qu'il ya une
incompréhension un problème de non pas
du tout perception côté français
président poutine décide ce qu'il a
envie de décider s'il a raconté le
contraire la veille un de ses
interlocuteurs étrangers ben tant pis
pour son nature culture à tanger un
double langage non les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui les écoutent
comme disait monsieur pasqua je crois
c'était on est dans ce type d'univers en
est c'est pas du tout
c'est une forme de fonctionnement assez
naturel chez chef vladimir poutine
derrière shaun deuxième chose
entre la reconnaissance des deux sat
rapide de l'est de l'ukraine et
l'invasion de l'ukraine tout entière et
il y à une étape intermédiaire qui a été
évoqué à plusieurs reprises cet après
midi au conseil national de sécurité
russe
sous la forme d'une question à laquelle
d'ailleurs président poutine s'était
promis de répondre mais n'a pas fait
visuellement ce soir la télévision
c'est la question de l'extension des
deux républiques séparatistes à
l'ensemble du territoire des deux
régions des deux oblast concernés
aujourd'hui seulement après qu'alpha
seulement 40 % environ de cette région
est occupée par les séparatistes pro
russes mais 60% reste entre les mains
des ukrainiens donc la question se pose
maintenant savoir si le président
poutine à la demande des deux
républiques indépendantes souveraine et
ainsi de suite va leur porter secours
pour occuper le territoire qui leur
revient j'ajoute t que le président
poutine en avait très brièvement parlé
dans sa conférence de presse à la suite
de son entretien avec le président
macron il y à une quinzaine de jours
s'était passé rigoureusement inaperçu
ç'a donné lieu par ailleurs à une chaîne
de farce il n'ya pas d'autre mot au
conseil national de sécurité quand il
est demandé à chacun ce que vous trouvez
que c'est une bonne idée que
que je que je reconnaisse les deux
république à lille avant chacun dit oui
chef c'est très bien et puis il a
demandé à son patron des services de
renseignements extérieurs ce qu'il en
pensait i wish r c'est une très bonne
idée de vouloir rapatrier ces deux
régions au sein de la fédération de
russie
poutine le fusille du regard en
réduisant mirent du temps mais c'est pas
du tout le sujet du jour ce sera
probablement pour un autre jour donc
cette affaire ouvre une nouvelle
séquence dont on ne connaît évidemment
pas les étapes quelles sont les
sanctions qui a été évoqué tout à fait
jouer vous interroger sur la position
américaine parce que pensez-vous de joe
biden a ouvert la voie en donnant le
sentiment que les américains
s'accommoderait d'une simple incursion
ce n'est pas une incursion pour
l'instant c'est un acte politique c'est
pas un acte militaire sur la
souveraineté d'un étang et le président
ano meetic qu'elle l'a qu'ils soient
parfaitement importants et graves et
ainsi de suite oui c'est pas mineur
l'amour le coup c'est pas une incursion
politique mineure fait une incursion
politique majeure
je pousse des séparatistes pour qu'ils
organisent leur région ensuite quand ça
m'arrange je vais leur reconnaître leur
indépendance
puis dans un troisième temps je vais les
absorber c'est l'attachement la place
est évidemment c'est évidemment grave et
mais c'est pas ce type d'incursions que
se réferrait le président biden au
moment où il s'est exprimé en fait il a
il il était dans un contexte où il
parlait d' opération militaire
éventuelle donc l'aurait pas faire dire
à bail donne des choses qui n'a pas en
l'occurrence dit
qui peut le plus peut le moins ça veut
dire que en l'état la situation actuelle
nécessite aucune réponse certes vous
demander par rapport à bayonne est-ce
que bolden
si maiden s'accommodait d'une incursion
vous n'estimez vous estimez qu'il n'y a
pas d'incursion à l'heure actuelle ça
veut dire que mme hayden peut se
contenter de la situation actuelle parce
que l'acte et politiques et de
militaires et de et politiquement l'acte
va être généralement considérée par
l'ensemble des états occidentaux comme
étant comme étant inacceptable ça se
maîtrise allemand n'est pas sur le
registre de la bonne nouvelle dans tout
chapeau le moment c'est que il ya de
fortes chances et qu'il n'y ait pas de
guerre majeure dans l'immédiat c